tant que personnage et j'aurais préféré
que j'ai plus de risques pour moi même
et que mes petits enfants courent moins
de risques pour eux
pour sauver ces gens qui sont pour la
plupart d'entre eux âgés eh bien on a au
fond on a sacrifié l'existence de toutes
les générations qui suivent qui vont
devoir payer la dette dans les années
suivantes et même c'est pas seulement
nos enfants et nos petits enfants qui
vont payer notre dette
et puis l'économie l'économie de toutes
les générations d'après et je trouve que
c'est tout c'est tout à fait affolant
pour tant que personnage et j'aurais
préféré qu'on aurait plus de risques
pour moi même et que mes petits enfants
courent moins de risques pour eux
je pense que papy et mamie comme comme
il dit on vient plus envie de voir leurs
petits enfants que de se protéger
absolument permanence pour préserver
leur vie sans aucune joie sans aucune
affection sans aucun contact
donc je trouve ça aberrant l'exemple le
plus probant c'est l'exemple des ehpad
où vous avez été quand même des gens qui
en général n'ont plus que quelques mois
voire quelques un petit nombre d'années
à vivre et qui préfère de loin voir
leurs petits enfants plutôt que d'être
préservée en permanence comme c'est le
cas depuis
enfin vous avez un certain nombre de
personnes âgées qui depuis presqu'un an
sont enfermés dans leur chambre pour
pouvoir préserver le peu de moi qui leur
reste c'est absolument fou comme système
de pensée on n'a pas besoin de faire
passer quand il faut la vie biologique
systématiquement avant tout
mais évidemment la santé c'est la
condition sinequanone de tous il n'est
pas la santé il ya beaucoup de choses
que vous pouvez pas faire la plupart
donc il faut d'abord être vivant pour
pouvoir vivre enfin lorsque la santé oms
vient annihiler tout le reste ça devient
absurde parce que nous avons besoin bien
sûr de manger
nous avons aussi besoin de nous cultiver
nous avons besoin de vie spirituelle une
partie en tout cas d'entre nous donc
c'est aberrant de tout sacrifier à cela
la vénus est une expression qui est
utilisé par un certain nombre de
philosophes aujourd'hui qui signifie
plusieurs choses différentes notamment
par par par michel foucault par giorgio
agamben bon et qui signifie plusieurs
choses différentes donc je ne veux pas
utiliser cette expression en laissant
croire que je suis en train de donner la
seule définition
donc je l'utilisent parce que elle peut
signifier aussi le fait de privilégier
le côté biologique des choses sur tout
autre côté le fait de penser que le la
santé qui a remplacé le salut depuis
quelques siècles les cartes avait déjà
dit la santé est l unique critère
important
je vous donne un exemple il est devenu
de plus en plus difficile dans nos
sociétés société contemporaine depuis je
dirais depuis le tournant du siècle et
il est devenu de plus en plus difficile
de considérer pour des parents que faire
courir des risques physiques à l'enfant
est important pour leur éducation
lorsque on envoyait des scouts faire des
camps il ya une cinquantaine d'années
ces scouts cours est des vrais risques
je me rappelle des scouts selon de la
montagne qui couraient des vrais risques
en montagne et les parents étaient
d'accord parce qu'ils estimaient que
courir ces risques ces risques physiques
c'était important pour eux pour
apprendre à devenir quoi je sais moi un
certain nombre de valeurs qui étaient
plus importantes en fait que la vie
aujourd'hui c'est interdit ça c'est
impossible quand vous faites des camps
scouts
vous avez tellement de de loi qui est de
règlement qui vous enserre que
finalement on pouvait plus qu aurait
aucun risque si jamais vous courir un
risque et qu'il arrive un malheur alors
là vous êtes responsabiliser vos
courriers en prison et ça c'est ça la
vie nue
[Musique]
une société peut pas devenir ni les
listes tout entière ça n'existe pas
c'est toujours quelques personnalités
comme ça qui sont d'ailleurs assez
amusante mais c'est pas ça qui fait une
société et vous n'avez pas de société
atti société a été inventé par les
occidentaux
vous n'avez pas de société qui puisse se
passer de spiritualité parce que nous
sommes mortels et nous sommes bien
obligés de demander ce qu'il apporte
donc les religions les spiritualités
vont renaître c'est déjà le cas nos
sociétés vont être reprises par enfin
tout cas cela semble là par un certain
nombre de de sagesse